le goff a baissé unity il se compose de
33 sauveteurs cette année ça 83 et
sapeurs pompiers nous avons dix chefs
d'unité et 23 sauveteurs qui ont pendant
toute l'année a subi ce qu'on appelle la
permanence permanence départementale une
couverture de tout le département au cas
où un risque particulier impliqué notre
notre engagement
donc je rappelle que le groupe si le
groupe de reconnaissance et
d'intervention en milieu périlleux dur
de la martinique
[Musique]
actuellement nous avons un accident de
travail ou le nombre a chuté de 10,2 m
les il a des douleurs au niveau du dos
ce que l'on fait on va essayer de donner
d'accueil sécurité vers le présent
[Musique]
oui les fans à ne rien leur reprocher